sie das gut
hey leute was glaube jetzt willkommen
beim neuen video ihr hört sich schon ein
bisschen an meiner stimme ich bin leicht
erkennen also die erkältung ist schon
wieder besser aber ist immer noch da
dennoch konnte ich mir natürlich nicht
nehmen lassen heute ein neues video für
euch zu drehen und ich habe mir für
heute wirklich was überlegt so ich weiß
gar nicht wie ich drauf gekommen bin
aber irgendwie bin ich halt drauf
gekommen und ich fange gerade ernst auch
ein bisschen sorgen meine stimme bei die
hat sich sogar für mich gerade ziemlich
schlimm und naja egal ich bin auf jeden
fall auf diese video idee gekommen
wahrscheinlich weil ich selber auf
musical ab und zu mal rumhänge und mir
ein paar sachen eindrücke auf jeden fall
weicht also unterwegs und das pferd
irgendwann so warum gibt es da so viele
zwillinge ich weiß wo gefühl jeder
zweite musik wie account besteht aus
zwilling ehrlich diese beiden deutschen
musik die zwillinge sind ja auch
zwillinge also lisa lena heißen dir und
ich glaube die haben sogar die meisten
follower auf ganz musik oder die zweit
oder dritt meisten irgendwie sowas zehn
millionen oder so das muss man sich vor
augen halten ich meine zehn millionen
die app gibt es ja noch nicht so lange
und habe einfach schon zehn millionen
follower das ist krass na ja gut wir
sind auch immerhin schon fast 50.000 ab
so ich sollte vielleicht langsam auf den
punkt kam auf jeden fall habe ich mir
noch die zweit und dritt meisten
erfolgten zwillinge auf musik lieder
ausgesucht und jetzt werden wir meinen
kassen vergleich wer sind denn die
besten musici zwillinge darsteller auch
ganz musik lied zur show kreativ oder
nicht zum einen haben wir da natürlich
lisa und lena zum zweiten haben wir da
max nh ray und zum dritten haben wir die
kannte ich vorher und ich habe mir
folgendes überlegt ich gucke mir jeweils
immer ein musiker von denen 1 1 von idan
als von denen und das drei runden lang
und werner frey und die meisten punkte
hat gewonnen als ich bewerte
die besten sollte nicht so gut an
musiklehrer können also leute wir fangen
an ich würde sagen wir statt einfach mal
mit maxxim habe keine ahnung wer die
kenn ich kann es wie gesagt vorher auch
nicht aber
hat wahrscheinlich so eine million light
ich will jetzt nicht so viel zu sagen
bayern und der erste music wie kommen
noch zwei weitere aber machen einfach
weiter mit
also was war ich schon immer können ich
weiß gar nicht ob das so schwer ist aber
ziemlich kugel irgendwie sieht das gut
aus
also das fand ich eigentlich ganz gut so
ich meine dass mit den händen man glaube
ich schnell er ich weiß nicht ich hab
mich gerade so wie alt sind die wohl
weil wir schon ganz hübsch ich finde
heutzutage kann man das gar nicht mehr
sagen die können 15 sein ihr könnt auch
schon 23 sein okay es kommen die dritte
zwillinge das in lisa und lena
die forscher
vor mir stand
das baby
ok ok sehr viele sagen ja immer für
musical braucht man eigentlich gar kein
talent man muss nur irgendwas machen und
krieg zehn millionen followern dass ich
ihn nicht ganz so also man muss ja
wissen wie es geht
man brauche jetzt vielleicht nicht so
das große talent aber ein kleines
bisschen talent muss schon da rein und
ich fand jetzt gerade wenn man mal
wirklich so darauf achte ich kann ja
nochmal kurz gucken so die synchronität
und dieses wegschubsen und dieses mit
dem finger das macht jetzt vielleicht
nicht so sind meiner meinung nach das
muss man schon drauf haben so ich
glaubwürdig das machen sieht es nicht so
gut aus ich würde jetzt vielleicht ganz
vorsichtig sagen weil ersten punkt
heilig aus und geht ein komplize ein
lena und ein punkt
weil die haben sich beide sehr gut
bewegt und ich glaube dass es gar nicht
so einfach dieses harvey einmal mehr
oder wie die heißen die haben ja einfach
nur besessen wir machen weiter runde
zwei okay man auch sagen auf musical
sind auch viele jüngere leute also
wirklich vielleicht 19 11 jahre findet
man sowas mit elf jahren lustig großen
respekt ab da ziemlich viele follower
deswegen welches gegen sagen aber ich
fand es jetzt nicht so kreativ
beziehungsweise besonders sie andy was
an dieser drauf gefallen liegen
wenn ihr auch was anderes als
ja toll die machen ja immer das gleiche
das muss sich also in die machen immer
so und das war's dann auch schon
aber was mich fasziniert hat ebenfalls
noch zwei jetzt ins 3 alles klar
ja
na gut das ist jetzt schwer zu sagen
hätte ich mir einfach ein musical von
mir meiner freude mit reinem seiner wird
mir die entscheidung jetzt deutlich
leichter fallen weil wir sind die besten
kein spaß ist nur wir sind halt keine
zwillinge dass das problem
okay weil das vor den harten arbeit
zwillingen gegen wie total und lustig
waren es hier wieder das gleiche gemacht
haben führt jetzt lisa in den er mit
zwei punkten und sie ähnlich hat ein
punkt so haben die hessen die heißen max
an harry und ich haben könnten
button holt jetzt bin ich auch sehen
baby-boom i co star in mexiko roberto
jugene vor bei der taxi orange oder pink
sheets war doppelt ohne auf dem mathäser
gibst du mir blumegg ihm das fand ich
jetzt gut ich dachte die können gar
nichts aber die können sich also ich
finds herzlich so schlecht vor allem für
das junge alter okay die können auch
schon 16 sein ich weiß es nicht aber
okay dann sind sie nicht im stimmbruch
die sind 13 sage ich jetzt einfach das
war gut für 30 jahre
ich meine ich kann es nicht besser die
promikon sexy doch okay das freut mich
gut mal gucken was ich mache und ich
mache jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder
irgendwie so
bis jetzt sei die zwillinge oder sind
das fünf gänge fünf teile frauen stehen
einander und bewegen sich auch tief
wahrscheinlich nicht weiß nicht was ich
dazu sagen soll und zum abschluss haben
wir noch mal gucken wer den letzten
punkt für sich entscheiden können doch
nicht die ersten beiden musicals von
denen deutsch besser das war jetzt
einfach nur zur musik bewegt und ein
bisschen gesprungen durch die haben
gehört deswegen geht für mich sehr
überraschend der dritte punkt an habe er
offen das heißt mariam 1 punkt sie hat
auch ein punkt lisa ein leder haben wir
zwei punkte
damit hätten sie theoretisch gewonnen
ich wünsche da kann man applaudieren
herzlichen glückwunsch zum ersten preis
listenpreis oder so was muss ich mal
gucken ob irgendwas mit zur schule
die russen was brauche ich selber ihr
könnt euch entscheiden zwischen
cornflakes und mainburg
ok dann herzlichen glückwunsch nach
mainz schlecht so leute bevor jetzt
unser musical account folgt ist bei kurz
eingeblendet wollte ich natürlich ganz
gern von euch wissen wer von diesen drei
top music handy usern zwilling findet
ihr am besten schreibt einfach in die
kommentare
und was ich dazu auch noch loswerden
wollte ich hab wirklich falschen respekt
vor allen drei so ich finde es auch gut
wenn man vom iris beckert auch immer
meine videos scheiße findet oder sagt
ich hab kein talent ein spaß aber ich
würde sagen jeder andere zwinge ich
genauso macht hätte er die chance dazu
liegen die ob musik oder youtube oder
instagram bekannt zu werden sowie die
dann warum nicht deswegen finde ich es
scheisse wenn man sagt ja die können gar
nichts zu mir könnte ich sagen kein
problem weil ich werde das nicht so oft
aber ich glaube die harzer dauernd als
ein bisschen talent galt auf jeden fall
dazu meiner meinung nach
deswegen ist sein thema ihr habt
gewonnen herzen glück und alles was mit
video ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
wenn es sich ein bisschen unterhalten
hat würde ich mich sehr freuen wenn ihr
genau jetzt einloggen
da lässt steckt auf jeden fall den
musiklehrer kommt auf jeden fall unsere
musical karte ab und ich würde sagen wir
sehen uns dann morgen oder übermorgen
mit einem neuen video jetzt kommt
wirklich wieder sehr viele videos so pro
woche glaube ich fünf hatte jetzt ein
geplant beziehungsweise 4 muss ich mal
schauen wir sehen uns wieder trennte und
instagram snapshot ps